حضرت الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه من احتمال
اصطدام مع حزب الله في لبنان في حاله
تصعيد وعقل رئيس شعبه الاستخبارات
العسكريه الاسرائيليه هارون حليفه قال ان
الامين العام لحزب الله اللبناني حسن نصر
الله يقترب من ارتكاب خطا قد يدفع المنطقه
الى حرب كبرى من جهته قال وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي
تخوض حرب استنزاف ضد اسرائيل
بوكلائها القريبين عبر الحدود في المقابل
قال مسؤول ايراني للجزيره ان اي اعتداء
عسكري سيقابل برد واسع وغير مسبوق تلك
المواقف جاءت بعد يوم من مناورات عسكريه
لحزب الله في جنوب لبنان حاكت اختطاف جنود
واقتحام مستوطنات
شهدنا في الاونه الاخيره بشكل واضح وحده
الساحات فمن وراء التهديدات الاتيه من غزه
ولبنان وسوريا والضفه الغربيه يوجد خط
موحد تقف من خلفه ايران فهي التهديد
الاخطر على استقرار المنطقه والعالم ايران
تخوض حرب استنزاف ضدنا بواسطه وكلائها على
حدود